what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I go over this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness so
guys today on Twitter you guys know me
and Twitter I'm always tweeting tweet
tweet tweet you know and so this week I
noticed a fight coming up now guys I
want to give you my background in sports
I really don't know much about fighting
I don't really watch sports it's just
not my thing I noticed Logan Paul was up
to fight a guy named Dylan Dennis
now how did I find out about this fight
because Dylan was roasting the [__] out
of Logan so Dylan announces that he is
fighting Logan on the 14th so as you
guys may or may not know Logan Paul
recently got engaged to Nina Agdal now
before this whole story I really didn't
know much about the chick until Dylan
really breaks the internet
by tweeting out a picture of Logan's
fiancee
with Leonardo DiCaprio how many men in
Hollywood and in entertainment are
dating Leonardo DiCaprio's exes because
Tom Brady married one of Leo's exes
Blake Lively that's another one it just
seems like every blonde chick in
Hollywood has dated Leonardo DiCaprio so
next he tweets
um another picture at him her with this
other guy I don't know who this is he
just Bombshells Logan with all of these
pictures of his fiancee either basically
nude with other men there's one
there LeBron James
oh my this is wow this is too many
this is just actually crazy wow wow now
I don't know
if these are photoshopped or real but
they look real now you know the internet
starts freaking out and they start
saying you know Dylan you're taking this
too far so there's a guy named fousey he
says you're effing scum Dylan that's his
wife hate on the man his character his
looks but why demonize his wife as if we
don't all have a past not cool bro
especially since you're doing this all
for clout and won't show up Fight Night
so Dylan says back this is coming from a
guy who took advantage of a drunk girl
who was an emotionally hurt sex
trafficking victim at an airport for a
[__] in the bathroom then bragged
about it on your stream
now again I don't know who any of these
people are but Dylan is an absolute
Savage he's like 10-0 okay so then next
I guess Dylan's ex-girlfriend comes in
it looks like Dylan dated a chick named
Alissa Violet so Alissa Violet who I
believe is an ex-girlfriend of Dylan's
I'm not sure but it seems like it based
on what I'm reading on Twitter Alyssa
says dude this is [__] up are you okay
now again this Dylan guy is like 10-0
because he responds and says dude this
is [__] up are you okay Alyssa Violet
claims she hooked up with ex Jake Paul's
brother Logan so I guess she dated oh no
she dated Logan
and then hooks up with Jake wow
there is no loyalty with these brothers
it's like
is there I thought blood was thicker
than water I guess not if there's a hot
[__] involved so then next right on top
of that he he goes even further and he
says you decided to share private texts
for clout which honestly seems weird and
cringe and now you're actually defending
this person
I was a little confused by this I think
that Dylan also dated this Alyssa chick
so there's beef because basically one of
the Paul's stole his chick
and so it's kind of like you know a lot
of times we're like why are you punching
but it looks like he's punching back
because initially he stole his chick did
a music video and now he's like all
right the gloves are off here's a
million pictures of your fiance with
basically everybody in the industry you
know
you know what's funny I don't even
I don't even think we care who wins this
fight because Dylan's already won and
the fight hasn't even started
I've never heard of this guy before this
so now Logan Paul is pissed and as the
true Alpha he is
he sends a legal notice to Dylan
demanding he stops posting photos of his
fiancee I mean I I don't want to be this
person but I'm guessing that she posted
all the photos first I mean and this is
the thing this is the issue we have with
the modern day wives is you know before
even if a chick did something she could
kind of forget I don't know what you're
talking about but now the internet lives
forever and this really should be a
message to younger women to really be
careful with who you date and you know
Choose Wisely because they will keep
pictures and receipts and tweet them at
you for the rest of your life so here
you go and it really also shows that you
know men are judged for the women that
they keep around men are judged for who
they associate with now Dylan also took
a meme so this is a meme of modern day
marriage right there's guy [__] the
chick [__] the chick and then the guy
to wife her and so now he put Logan Paul
wow this guy is like 10-0 he's like 10-0
and I guess this guy has also I saw some
tweets where I guess he dated a hoe too
and he was a little bit mad because he's
like when everyone was tweeting
um pictures of my chick with everybody I
didn't block no cease and desist I just
took it
now would you say it's an unmanly thing
to block somebody and send a cease and
desist letter I don't know
I can't imagine so now Logan Paul
responded he put out this video if
you're so confident in your boy I got a
bet for you I bet Dylan but he's a broke
[__] I got a million dollars that says
I beat your boy on October 14th come on
bro come on I know you kicked up see how
confident you are imagine all the coke
you can buy you [__] drug addict two
dummies one night October 14th I'm
[__] you both up okay so he's like so
Logan comes back and he says you know
what you were a Brokey sir you have no
money but Dylan is just 20-0 he says he
says bro has the money to bet a million
but he can't pay off the people he scam
that's crazy Logan punches but Dylan
punches harder I don't even care who
wins this fight because Dylan is like 54
and zero he is winning he's he's got a
million pictures of his chick with other
men
now he tried to call him broke and Dylan
calls him broker he has plausible
deniability because
Logan stole his chick he's got his chick
with literally everybody in the industry
that's a cute dog though that is a cute
dog this this really again drives the
point home that men have really adapted
to the market number one
you know they say that sex is a need for
men and it really shows because a
hundred years ago if you weren't a
virgin
you really weren't going to get that
ring you were done but now we have a
hundred years later or at least if
anyone found out
we have multi-millionaire rich men
marrying ex-hoes